so
[Music]
so i just had a wonderful insight here
talking with my
with my buddy edgar and it was it was
basically about
well it was about the importance of play
right it was about the importance of
not taking things too seriously right to
to
to play to bring play to bring
make believe to bring active costuming
to the doorstep of every
moment right to to be in place to be
like a child that deploys
imagination and and the very act of
deploying his imagination upon the
landscape
enchants the landscape which becomes a
self-evident truth
the world is enchanted the child at play
both creates
and perceives his world but as adults we
can
we can lose sight of that ability we can
grow stale
we can forget that everything's a
costume
and that everything's a choice that we
can be who we want to be but we get set
in our ways
we get blinded by the matrix of
behaviors we get kind of
programmed and socialized into a
rigidity where we've accepted the role
that's been given to us and we
forget that we can change who we are and
we can costume ourselves and we can
change ourselves we can
we can always revivify and reinvent we
can put the self aside if it doesn't
serve us and come alive again in a new
way character is like a wardrobe
fair enough okay but but but for those
people that are stuck in a rut and that
have
forgotten the fundamental plasticity
of our lived experience that our very
field of awareness is a tabula rasa a
creative act that we can
author moment to moment like the mythic
playwrights of our own lives
we forget this right how do we remind
ourselves of this
here's where feedback loops come in what
we need more of
is not so much for human beings to play
more but for human beings to be prompted
to play more see i don't think people
would refuse the opportunity
for play if they were prompted into play
you go to a place like burning man the
very infrastructure of burning man
is a prompt the art is a prompt
olivia steals typography across the
deserts writing words in a gigantic
manner
call attention to themselves which
really is calling attention into you
everything is a prompt into play a
prompt
into questioning a prompt into the
fundamental plasticity of reality a
prompt
to question those aspects of yourself
that have cemented in those aspects of
the world that seem beyond
transformation and change
yeah burning man prompts you into play
and so
today you know you broke these these
glasses that you're wearing
and the fact that you broke them later
on
turned them into a reminder or very much
a design
insight a prompt about the importance of
prompts
in evoking play and bringing more play
into our lives and it led to a
conversation about
costuming like like intentional
costuming not all of us get to be actors
assuming roles and putting on the
costume but the costume takes you there
so
if we could like do like a weekly
costume party
you know like a weekly dionysian
celebration where in addition
to wine and cannabis and food and music
you also bring you also bring a costume
right you put on something unusual an
idiosyncratic that calls attention to
itself
and that shakes people of seeing you the
way they normally see you
and then you wear the costume show up at
the party and then forget about it
because the point is
once you're wearing it forget about it
but what will happen is throughout the
evening you will be continuously
prompted into play
every time you see your friends funny
looking glasses you'll chuckle you'll
laugh you'll be in song and dance and
all of a sudden
your expectations of who this person is
are inverted by the costuming which
inverts everything which makes
everything
more playful and joyful and subversively
wonderful because you're
liberated from the constraints on
behavior that normally cast themselves
upon you
and you become the free brave reckless
god that lives within us all
that's why people go to transformational
festivals to be transformed
and the first step to transformation is
costuming
the realization that all is a costume
that you can costume and change and
actively window dress your life it can
be the most
fabulous shopping window in the history
of the world
be that character and then kill him and
then create another one
you keep revivifying and reinventing
like a modern day charlie mingus riff
and rhapsodized through a tumbling
thicket of ideas and reflections with
such a sharp and vital alacrity
that it can take the breath away be the
author of your story be the active
costume designer set designer writer
author playwright and star
[Music]
be the playful one
she's